you
and I'm sort of eclectic and not reckon
system so I don't really know how it all
happens but I tend to be very curious I
like to read a lot I think a lot of I
think I'm relatively simplistic and I
sort of just bring two two disparate two
or more disparate things together so I
think a lot of it is just bringing stops
from one field to another field and just
taking a different approach I think
that's like that's sort of the way it
goes back to sort of how we can how tree
hugger and planet green tan can help and
sort of what what's left to do I think
one of the big pieces is just that that
is social currency and let me explain I
think we're very social beings we really
care much more than we acknowledge much
more than we often think we really care
about what other people think and I
think you can get cool you can sort of
get a glimmer of this when like there's
their stats on people being asked about
public speaking versus death and you
know a lot of people are like
there-there sort of more nervous about
public speaking than death so it just I
think sorry illustrates like it's that
people are really concerned so this
social currency is very important so
what other people think is appropriate
and what other people think is not and
so I hope that through planet green both
the the channel and the the websites we
could help develop that because I think
it's a very powerful thing and we really
need it to happen so literally getting
down to you know it's just having a
private jet it was cool in the 80s it's
just not that cool anymore and same
verse or big houses and big cars and and
on the other side just there's respect
for people who are actually working and
or taking moves in the personal or their
working lives to align
their lives with their values and so I
think I think that's really important
and I think we can a great example is
from the is the littering from the 70s
like early in the early 70s it was
common to be driving down the road and
you'd see someone open the window and
throw bag of garbage out and threw a
whole bunch of different approaches like
fines for littering like the PSAs give a
hoot don't pollute the American chief
with the tier and the that's really
change so now it's like it's unthinkable
that you will be driving behind someone
and if they would do that and I think
that really illustrates that how much
stuff can change and how how important
it is what people think and so I think
that planet green can can serve a big
purpose instead of helping helping
salute the heroes and also point out the
you know the what's appropriate and
what's not
you